my name is Dennis caller so today
because the team is about the pawn the
pawn structure so I'd like you know just
to make like a little bit of historic
trip entry to explain how it developed
so hey when the first masterful chess
and the beginning out to get some great
out the game the polls really were not
so important for them much more
important was the peace activity so
that's why you know it it happened quite
logically there was some opening lines I
Kings gambit much more you know
sacrificial type of opening a bird wire
but just even from the beginning some
much like leader began to understand you
know the importance of the pawns in my
opinion the first world champion who had
like a good grip of some position of
fundamentals was attained is the first
world champion although in some way he
was just a very good tactician and he
was a bit dogmatic so probably this is
the case why the second world champion
Oscar the second world champion in my
opinion he's like incredible row because
he really began to understand how
complex his chess know how you can
balance different factors and maybe
because of these better understanding as
far as I remember this was the most
convincing match between Alaska and
Stein's I mean he just crushed eyes of
course it it helped a lot that he was
like the standard case of the young lion
dethroning the yacht lion he had more
energy but still he was like
understanding chess he was like a really
better player so that's why he had like
such a crushing victory I mean I do not
even remember our world champion she met
with such a great dominance I mean you
really had the impression that one place
is much better so the result was quite
logical so when we speak about the pawn
structures it's very useful to see how
it how it developed how how they played
what kind of openings and how they
develop you know the whole concept of
palm structures how he dictates you know
the the fashion in the openings so but
just to mention that last year the
second world champion he also showed
that because he began to play like quite
modern lines
he sometimes played c5 he played even c5
Knight 6 1965 which now he called
sveshnikov but ok we also call it Alaska
variation so he had like a very good
flexibility a deep understanding of
chess but mostly you know in this
ancient times the most popular with the
symmetrical opening lines because ok
they want it it is easy to understand I
mean they were like the pioneers of
chess so they wanted just like more
stable pawn structures like better to
handle like the Sicilian spawn
structures and more complex so usually
white play on the kingside and black
play on the queenside a symmetrical so
it needs it like a lot more subtleties
so they used to play so II 45 when it
gets a little bit out of fashion just to
sacrifice pawns
quite easily they begin to play like a
very similar to our openings 93 96 we
should be 5o this was quite popular in
it always will be popular because it's
quite a logical move you know trying
immediately all the the moves which we
saw on the blood pressure the center
Bishop c4 also develop the between a
very good position but it's not you know
direct pressure on the center even for
example here if we move back d4 which is
like a more modern approach which
Kasparov used it playing exactly on this
on how you treat palm structures that's
why he played so much scotch in the
mattress with with carpet but it's like
a [ __ ] opposed this would be five will
always be fashionable because like it's
a clear strategic play now in the modern
times because ok they used to play this
with a6 which now the most active moves
in the most popular moves or 86 or 96
you may see that the most active moves
well a 6 of course immediately comes in
hand with our question about the pawn
structures because then they can take on
c6 I just take from c6 and now you have
the first decision whether you take with
the b-pawn with or with the D pawn all
the strategic textbooks are very right
we think that whenever you can you can
take in direction towards the center
because this is like the
the standard station but there are a lot
of exceptions and even in the most
popular opening like the rule op is the
Spanish game DT is a very obvious
example of exception of this row because
here at least very quickly the pair of
Bishops gets into play the bishop can go
to g4 so it helps our development that's
why this exception is used to understand
you can grab me near to the pole because
if you grab the pawn he plays Queen
deplored our tech he gets it back but in
these all the times I want you just to
understand how they treated the the pawn
structure so they used to play d6 a very
solid move not not a bad move at all I
mean no doubt about that after that it
came a slightly more subtle approach
supposed to include a6 Bishop a4 d6 the
so cost I needs defense but in a better
version but then used to play d6 which
it just like on one negative point it is
slightly passive it slightly closes the
dark world Bishop but it's a very solid
line so as far as I remember they used
to play quite a lot no d4
of course you can play in other ways but
this like the most active approach
immediately trying to to fight for the
center Bishop d7 now getting out of the
pin and also indirectly defending the
pawn on e5 because if you take on c6 and
I take and take 25 the pawn on e4 is not
defended 93 here
it's interesting how how it developed
here one very interesting detail until
what moment you can still you know
sustain the pressure in the center so in
this the way they played in the opening
gives us a lot of material and I think
it's very beneficial to study in this
out opening life not because now they'll
be quite frequently played against you
but just to understand how chest
developed it gives a lot in in a in
getting a better position of you of
chess so Knight c3 defending the pawn 96
still you know he keeps pressure on e4
if you take on CC so you still can win a
pawn
let's say week a so Bishop e7 still if
you take on c6 he'll be able to take
music bishop secretary only five night
takes when info and after rookie one
here is probably the first important
moment although I just have to make one
one important distinction here white can
play they were sweet hope the main theme
is about poor escape white can play
interesting approach taking on c6 Bishop
takes here queen d3 also you're not
trying just to frost that design center
whether he takes from d4 Knight takes d4
and then having more space although
black has two bishop in a solid position
but have less space you can if you take
some d4 Knight takes d4 B 3 which would
be to rock a over a a e1 f4 with a more
active position this is like more
difficult to play for black if you wants
to still to keep you know the tensioning
he has to play 97 but okay here he has
to give you know some temples d5 Knight
c5 the only way to save the piece Quincy
for let's say we should be saying Bishop
e3 still gaining some time threatening
Bishop c5 95 so this is an interesting
approach in quite quite good in in my
opinion but in this ancient time it was
quite popular to play it like rook e1
and like I told you earlier it's
interesting
can they still sustain that the pressure
they have to take on d4 well this is
like a easy question but still it's good
to know because as far as I remember it
was a game tersh Marku which answered
this question although of course many
other games could have shown this but I
think this was the first game I saw I
mean when I was very young
why you can sustain anymore the pressure
for example if you caso here let's see
for example let's check out one first
line take here take taken in five take
went five now do we take when 85 or
first we exchange the Queen's exchange
the Queen's because if we first take
that you're taken while
the defenders of d4 pawn will be gone so
he will get back the material so we
exchange we take here well of course
here we have to take with the roof deck
with the bishop it makes no sense KITT
Knight takes 25 plus 1 porno here we can
take with both of of the rooks let's say
if we take okay let's just take with
this hook which makes less sense but ok
now you'll see why I'll take the pawn so
you have to take on e4
take right ok if not you simply has lost
upon and of course you can take I mean
there's no need if you take with the
with the night only for we play
intermediate move taking on c6 in your
resign basically so you take money for
because you're only tactical but a good
hope is the we class rank but here he
plays a very easy move how we cover the
last ring and we still keep pressure on
the alignment for his bad luck is a
couple of pieces so it's not very easy
to get them all out in one moment what
will be like your the the normal move
for white which really challenges the
whole approach of black of keeping the
tension one more move so castling is
they have taken on d4 and giving up you
know the in the fight for the center but
making like we will see a very solid
pollution what will be the move here for
white if they want to prove that black
is wrong keeping the tension for one
more move way I could you jump with the
nighty-night it's really and I get
really exactly 93 and I'm asking okay
what about the pin now and okay to play
a 5 i play after ii let's let's look
okay this is appear after you check King
f1 and okay bad news so
so here now let's check let's check
because it makes slightly more
challenging to take with with this route
because okay the rookin on f8 in this in
this position can be helpful so let's
let's see the same line take care take
take take plane ID 3 and now f5
well now the thing is it on f3 if you
play Bishop c5 check if I play King f1
what will play because now the pin on
the King on f1 is working for black so
he can just play Bishop e6 now Bishop e6
no material losses we okay no you take
out taken that out play chief chief
chief I know on Knight f4 but ok here
this fast I remember this game establish
this although this can be calculated
over the broad on Bishop c5 tariffs was
good enough player to see another you
know tactical detail which has to do
with the geometry of the chessboard so
now he changes that's why tactic is very
important risk it takes here you take
with a knight Bishop g5 now you see
what's coming now we should be fair and
our tech and there is no way to to save
the night because if you play here the
same thing here
rook e8 and now what's the move which
ends the whole sequence see fallen ok
you lose material and you lose it badly
I mean probably see forking observe and
take take take a look against Knight is
a very simple technical decision so this
as far as I remember was answering you
know this question right here they even
played earlier they take on d4 so they
have to give up the tension in the
center but still maintain a very solid
position here also there is an
interesting approach how they played
this type of vision nowadays it's Martin
because the whole concept of the pawn
structures becomes more and more subtle
so they play castle we'll take a look
because I just want to give you an idea
but in the past they in it's quite
understandable they didn't want to have
like more complex constructs with double
pants because really with the doubled
pawns we'll see you have to be careful
exactly what they are doing because they
are so mobile they can be weakness not
only in the endgame but even in the in
the middle game we'll take a look so
they were playing Knight takes on d4
Quinn takes from d4
well we can take on this here but really
no need you know to help the opener to
develop the Queen on d7 Queen on on d4
in here you also have a choice because
let's be honest Black has a very solid
position he's probably minifig has less
space now but okay this is one problem
which is the Marches let's prove it it's
not enough so even you have more space
you have to pressure you have to develop
some weaknesses in the open and scamp
and here they were playing Bishop b5
also they can play castle on Castle I
guess I mean the normal logic should be
here the plate to maintain more pieces
because you have more space so you need
more pieces because when you have more
space in the enemy has more piece in his
camp so here's more problems how to
maneuver them but also another very
important aspect one of the most
important with space is time in chess so
okay if you move Bishop f1 he'd pitch
okay move but you lose one tempo so okay
that's why it's possible in my opinion
just to play Bishop take on d7 Queen
takes from d7 b3 of course you can take
here let me show you
Knight takes from d7 also another move I
can play Knight d5 I still have like a
small but okay a pressure I mean you can
play Bishop f6 I can play Queen before I
have more space and you have some
problems here for example you have to
decide how you defend the pawn if you
have to weaken your pawn structure if
you play Knight c5 Bishop e3 so quinta X
from d7 and here also a logical
development of the bishop which prevents
further exchanges because if further
exchanges occur in this position it
helps you know the site which has less
space
so you can play something like b3 let's
say rook e8 these are these are not for
a smooth but in my opinion looks quite
logical let's say here and now you have
more space and you can
let's double here that the heavy pieces
and after he defends the palm on a seven
because he can follow suit you know
doubling that because on a 70s defend
like let's play a six
I can play 92 Knight f4 and start you
know pressuring a bit so probably
because of that here they used to play
there are some quite curious games you
can see mean in many textbooks is fives
I won I remember quite vividly here
taking and now Castle well one of the
most famous game was a scary with black
against parish when he just put the rook
in the middle the center provoking
parish interest was much better in my
opinion the middle game but away the
Oscar was a very good tactician he was a
very good all-over player I mean
positional tactician so ok did this
helped a lot so this game was as far as
I'm a Bishop g5 age six bishop age 48
but he also white can try I remember
there was like a friendly game between a
car Blanca in a much weaker player so
here probably this was the reason that
cab Blanca played at Queen's III you
know attacking here on c7 although it's
really not like a real real attack
because you can make like a simple move
you can play a six because you can't
take with the night because of the pin
no roots yet but if I have to be honest
in my opinion it's even better just to
play a more developing move like Queen
d7 on a4 a6
so okay the pawn on a four you know
sometimes game can be a problem although
sometimes you can use the rook lift rook
a3 but it's hard to envision now
happening so now Queen d7 it's better
because you still can't take here
because of the pin I guess taken with
the Queen on c7 he's also suspicious it
always should be suspicious because I
can
like here take here and play something
like Quincy six now
and the rookie 8 is coming the Queen
feels trapped if Bishop a4 room d8 and
still rook e8 so you have to sacrifice
the Queen which is not really the yeah
and my idea of Queen d7 is that if you
play like 94 you win some time so you
can play something like rook e8 95
Bishop f8 which should be okay for for
black they have a quite decent position
which is completely the opposite which
this open a locker blank I think his
name was funner off I've never heard of
him but he was like a player they played
like friendly game he played c6 which is
really losing time and also making the
post Rancher worse because now on d6 the
pawn is having some problem and you're
giving time of you're open to put their
piece on active position and they are
followed just as far as I remember this
game here here
Queen g3 ten per move 95 now no need to
play immediately Bishop h6 because you
play 96 Blanca played Bishop f4 27 I
repeat this was a friendly game Rudy one
Rudy eight and I feel because it was a
friendly game at Kerr Blanc was a much
better player it happened to all of us
instead of playing something probably
queen eight three putting pressure
because 194 you can play Queen before
and still putting pressure like if you
take on b2 I can take
Luke takes from d6 b5 now b5 looks some
kind of unpleasant but okay you can play
beat we know because on c5 it hangs from
B if I can on any five probably you can
use some tactics like Quincy five you
know still keeping pressure and and now
you see now the pawn structure will not
be good if you take on c5 and with all
these and I care for against not only
four against three but when I Khushi
five your Bishop will be crying out loud
how they say but here comes Lanka care
blanca plata one of the very famous of
his small combinations rook takes from
d6 probably you've all seen it but just
to repeat it from a curious point to you
here
and now Bishop e5 no he's opening like I
said because it was a friendly game
probably didn't think too much or maybe
he got a little bit fancy so here he
missed her not too difficult to find
move okay he do we don't know where it
was played this game at least I don't
know maybe it was played in a cafe so it
was not so easy to spot it maybe there
was noisy but well what what move kick
he missed here double attack with a
queen
he played 51 you play Trudy one fancy
move and that's why he entered in the
chest history if you just played the
other move will never probably get rid
of for now photo probably the guy
deserved
yeah qualify for a double attack and
okay here the position is not clear at
all you know Bishop d3 I think but I
think it's okay for for black I mean
I've looked at some fourth line but okay
black and white can you never away claim
that they are winning no I think and I
think not not winning but something like
here you take I mean you have to take no
and now you play route g6 no because
it's a table or techno to play here I
check you you play here
I take well we are talking about pawns
no pawn structure so okay taken with the
F pawn will be a very bad you know about
the the pawn so he takes with the H bomb
[ __ ] Queen City okay I don't believe
it with this scattered pawn structure
white can claim anything so probably
it's an equal position but for our maybe
for our what we play this super fancy
move
ruled e1 which shot the imagination so
we have to be honest we have to give the
people because because of that we like
because of all these players will our
chess we've learned a lot and we've
continued there out if they were not
will be having a lot of lot of problems
and not having an idea about chess so d1
here Bishop e5 and okay here is a famous
combination on the theme of deflection
have anybody seen it all of you have
seen this combination combination is
night h6 here and deflection in last
rank and of course phone are off because
of that here he was he was in the in the
chest case the rear so 95 like 800 caso
but are a Quincy trees speculatively in
my opinion not the best move well Bishop
g5 here is what tariffs plate again
Alaska is a very logical move because at
least you can continue like if you
continue like a norm of let's say I I
want to ask you that questions because
to be interesting
you play Queen d7 what do you think it
make this move a dubious one if I hear
if I've looks very unpleasant no if I
because the bishop is hanging on e7 and
in this person probably if we look a
little bit take I mean like this
probably is lost no I mean I play here
I can play rookie three double because
you can't take because of H phone oh
yeah it looks okay with this pawn on the
penultimate rank I mean nothing good
will happen probably so I remember from
my younger years that when I've looked
at these positions so okay there is a
one guy which was incredibly talented he
used to work with Tao but he has some
other other problems with tolling he was
a grand master from a Latvia incredible
talent and he is open and played this
move which makes sense because like when
you have less space you want to exchange
some pieces also interesting Nyjah for
although in this famous game he played
last curve h6 let's just first here
rook e8 Rudy 197 Bishop takes 27
objection Quincy 3 now it makes sense
no because he to install to weaken you
and on 690
night at five and here is the famous
last year rook
you know rookie rookie five and he got
the rook here on the fifth rank when
it's in quite danger but technically he
was able to cope although this is a
famous game is if tariffs played
Benatar's played quite well just in one
moment me some tactics so he was having
an advantage so in last year understood
quite well he played that because he
didn't want like a tuition with less
passion a very clear plan because white
one it 94-95 queen g3 or the piece in
the center I mean classical playing I
mean Terrace played simply was gross a
much better player so this is one of the
the reasons so what I've mentioned
earlier is it here with Tony Simon work
is game night h5 take take and now
because we are talking about pawn
structure and how it went on you know
the understanding of these subtleties
how it became less more and more deep
he plays King okay the first move e5
it's not not too difficult if I because
okay if I take I take with the rook the
knight is hanging and I want to create
on d6 not only something that I can grab
but even a potential weak pawn no of
course we'd black I don't remember who
played with Victorian particular solid
player so okay actually played like the
most natural move rook e8 asking okay
what about the pawn on e5 because okay
the pin now is working in my favor not
the only move Queen d1 but I liked how
he played it night here 94 okay because
Queen d1 just defends the row can also
take on d6
because every end game you have like
problem because I have like you know
this concept to pawn islands I have like
three pawns three pause and you have one
on d6 here to pawn stood so difficulties
in the endgame not counting at my knight
now in this precise amount is more
active so neither for g3 and now Queen
d7 a very logical move now still you you
can see that in the game it's very very
close to completely quality so now c4 I
think yes
for now he played I think here here
right here 96 which helps him not to
have any kind of porn weakness but still
in this game is files animators veto
leash is well known for incredible
attacking style incredible you know
ideas skills
one of the the guys who gave the the
idea of Tao of the pool Gasca variations
of the Sicilian night off to sacrifice
although it didn't went very well in the
match with blow guys get very famous
match but we had so many ideas and oh it
don't meet sacrificing incredible talent
like I thought because of his help he
couldn't show all of his potential but
incredible talent so here he gets out of
any pawn witnesses taking here 26 and
keeping the game very close to
completely quality because the material
is eco I don't have any pawn witnesses
three on three so but ok I have slight
initiative like Rudy one probably on
Queen before he wants to play be 326 and
now Queenie for take take and still in
this endgame and keep it brilliantly the
endgame as far as I told in this game
and maybe in general he has some
advantage the advantage is probably
based on the fact that you have moved
just one pawn on a six so if you take
mine I didn't go to c5 and your paws are
not in perfect condition so you can play
b6 if you play now b6 I can play 93 95
and challenging your pawns so a small
initiative maybe with very good defense
Carson maybe capitals best we will get
depended but I remembered he was not
able to to cope with the times
maybe the game my memory went something
like King f8 f 4 f 6 5 95 or probably
probably ok maybe I can really play it
here
f4 king of 7 f5 here 95 now this is the
square which is unpleasant and now on
basics the guy went into a favorable
who can game with which move yeah 96 in
rope design check yeah and when to want
to twin a very very good game I mean
really really something special so ok so
this you see how in this position with
almost no pong weaknesses but with less
space you have to be very careful so
maybe that's why more the more modern
approach when you're taken d4
let's get back a little bit they just
make castle very recently when I played
now at the end of the same button I saw
one game of a young player international
master he played with John Bryant which
is already just needs a little bit of
ready to become a grandmaster also he's
older than they are play but also a very
young player and they played this
position and I remember this one from
the note he had incredible books
John Nana and he was incredible play but
he had too many interest he was very
intelligent in astronomy that's why
maybe he didn't which he full potential
in chess but worried maybe he didn't
need ok so here in this game Bishop take
some physics now I'll tell you about the
game which I remember for non-parties
because it was in one of many books of
nun which I've read although he lost I
think this game but he was having a
completely winning position so Bishop
takes on physics
BTech from physics so why would the pawn
so this is like an important question
well you can take with the with the
bishop because ok the the logic is when
you have less space
I've already told you that when you have
less space and you exchange you know
more pieces this means that you know the
question of space is not so important
because not too many pieces to find them
the right places but on Bishop T is
exciting it why should not take you know
the bishop on physics just plain into
into blacks hands it's not a bad move
but maybe it's better just to play
Knight f5 because with this pawn
structure the pawn on e4 maybe some
other pawns on on white you need the the
dark squared bishop so it's better to
exchange you know this bishop on e7 and
if you play let's say rookie
I can't keep pressuring you know like
with Bishop Bishop g5 Queen D for coming
so a bit of pressure No maybe not not so
much maybe the more logical just to play
97 at least you know you want Bishop f6
and if we each change it on e7 I take
with the Queen fairly solid position
still I think when you talk about bone
structures it makes more sense to me
here we try to play when I'm looking at
equation 95 take and now how do you
think it's interesting your opinion how
will it take on d5 what do you think is
like the better decision from a pressure
point of view you take with a pawn or
you take with a queen well if you take
with a poem it helps you know you put a
pawn on a light square it helps get more
space but it gets one defect in my
opinion I may be wrong but you know it
has only one open tile which can become
like in many opening lines like the line
above okay I'm calling it in your line
of debt everything in exchange on this
line and it's very difficult to create
when you take with the Queen in my
opinion you have more space and you
start you know trying to create you some
real bone weakness so here probably it's
more difficult for him in the other way
it's much more easier to exchange pieces
you know playing Bishop f6 hook' trying
to exchange the Queen afraid the other
okuni at exchange he'll maybe it will be
of course I'm not claiming at all at
this position it is like bad for for
black but I guess like more problems you
know he has to defend quite carefully
for a long period of time this will not
be like a pigeon which I really like
like to play with black although I
probably probably the engine will say
that this position is slightly worse for
black but in public he would defendant
okay we are talking about us about human
soul beat I should c6 here probably
because of 95 in my opinion and now what
I told you about this game which I saw
like maybe less than two months ago here
they played a move which I never liked
probably there is such an opening line
but
he was the name of the white player
white where it was with B I don't even
exactly keep a queen f3
something like Ruki 895 take take a kilo
this game right and okay he can play
different things even Knight said Queen
d7 with the tempo hello don't see any
problem with black and they even went on
to on a very important for them game it
was maybe in the seventh round or maybe
the eighth round
so here the right approach which I
remember from this old game of none
wants to play b3 Bishop b2 and just try
not to to put some additional problems
why because of the pawn structure so the
pawn structure on c6 d6 in season is
less mobile so it has some problems so
this game of non portage I cannot record
yet but probably twenty something like
that let's say play here here let's say
here like Rudy one Bishop here h3 just
in case project and then you want to
play Knight f3 and start threatening
because of of his pawns not just
rattling if I fall the time to make his
pawns really weak and they can have some
problems on the on the dark squares so
it's about torn structure so this
portion c6 d6 d7 you have to to use them
that they are not so so mobile if you
just keep doing nothing that there'll be
okay but okay this plan like that or
maybe portage played something like that
Knight f3 and e5 is a constant
positional threat you know just to make
it in them if you take on e5 then you
have problems with a real weak bones and
if we exchange the dark squares then you
have not only weak pawns but one of the
problems just probably you've read that
one of the poles with the weak pawns
he's not only the pawns but it means
that the squares in front of them are
also weak because the cons are you know
like let's imagine c16 and c-17 it means
that the c5 squares also on and when you
change the bishops it means it's
eternally eternally
week which means that almost every
endgame is very close to losing whether
it's a night against Bishop not
even talking about some other pieces the
rookin game is unpleasant so big
problems out of the dista more the the
the pawn structure yes
so here i think it'd be three playing
according police pawn structure
i'm not claiming he's like that the best
move not much knowing although i was
playing for many many years you know ii
for and principled life but i think it's
the more simple and i've seen it in the
similar action i think the only game i
remember was this nun with portage in
portage was a rather good please no
player and this game very quickly he
because of this plan which looked with
neither three threatening the position
of if i he got into serious are simply
none because of his time trouble just
corner the winning advantage in when we
talk about the the pawn structures today
like in the afternoon I was playing
blitz here in a studio and there was one
a one game which just you know a few
hours ago which I I want to show you
when I talk about porn structures oh it
was blitz
okay it was Blitzen on three minutes but
okay before that let me just okay during
the game out I'll show you about the
opening like so okay in this game I
don't know the open what was his name
like a additional player here a six okay
so II six we are different more water
will get into a one normal line of the
Catalan okay let me just tell you a few
words about the open air o'clock wait
the opening of always have some flaws so
you can control everything like the
opening repre I'm playing in this in
this game was created and this is a food
about a student of mine ago a young girl
she's now Tyson
hello no she's not a professional chess
player but she achieved quite a few
success even became world school
champion in her age group so we'd heard
there was a problem you know that she
was always telling just with me but
almost never look at it out when she was
alone so I had to create a chess a
portal which was mainly consist of ideas
and not of first opening lines and
especially with white with black coin
you need to know a little bit more
of lines because okay quite a much more
aggressive but we'd white and that's why
many years ago I tried to play the
opening reply credit for her
let me show us and then I paid for a few
years just to shock her that it can be
played so the opening I cried for her
was 93 d5 Bishop f4 but with ideas
almost in every situation very different
from the approach of the loaner system
which come she was playing which he was
playing it incredibly well because he's
a great player but ok it was a different
approach like in these positions
I paid Bishop e2 and always just in some
situation you can put the pawn on c4 but
I then I always put the pawn on c4 so I
played more actively so this was great
for her and also if they play and you
try to avoid all kind of opening like
like the Kings Indian the groom felt
almost everything of course it has flaws
so most of the prison you're trying to
play for a very very tiny advantage
almost not a non-existent after g6 I and
of course I never wanted to show what to
play against everything the same thing
so Bishop back for or against everything
I don't like it I don't think just to
give you my idea so if you play it like
again c6 Bishop f4 it's possible many
players play not talking about the
totals best like castle he can play
everything and play it well because he's
incredible player but here b6 Bishop e7
should be very you know solid for black
to say the least
also if you played Bishop a4 with g6
it's also it has some flaws so here
after he 6 g3 like a paid here on g6 I
taught her to play like Bishop g5 Bishop
g7 92 and to play whenever they play we
know with d5 of see if I to play it
Syrian to play against the bishop on g7
the main surgical idea trying to prove
further in the middle game to the bishop
of g7 has much less role that then it's
expected it's a whole concept you know
how to play the opening of course if
they play let's say Castle c3 they play
with d6 then like in many lines
I try to play it in the most active way
so I'm not playing it passively I don't
like you know to play play so I played
Bishop c4 Quincy we need to it quite a
few ideas in that and I think it's so
interesting operetta it does not we have
to be objective he doesn't expect
anything special because ok you can
avoid all the main lines inspect and be
quite ambitious in the opening so I want
to just first to explain you about the
opening cocking what hip yeah just the
broadness so Andy for 96 93 a6 g3 so
here of course you're giving away
something and quite a few things they
can play b5 already I have some ideas
with wife quite a decent move grabbing
some space they can play even like in
this game my hope and play d5 Bishop g2
b5 game can be played on the fault move
also a very solid line for black they
can play even a challenging line like
this one take take d5 okay so ii 5 which
in very recent game i forgot what i have
analyzed in one position so instead of
what was an allison okay this comes with
the age i played the same idea but in a
slightly different position which was
absolutely nothing so i got absolutely
nothing the other one at least it has
like a resemblance of a teller so it's
interesting but okay it happens you know
like i like i told you these are in this
i have never played i've analyzed it
like years ago i've never played it so
you can play 90 64 then it becomes sort
of a catalan so in this game which now
we will see to my open please game from
the day he played e5 just show before
here Bishop e7 castle castle
so I'm postponing c4 for some reason the
reason is that you get away out of quite
a few alliance of the Catalan which I
prefer not to play and of course you
give something to black like it's always
with the open area you give like I told
you b5 on the on the fraud move b5 on
the third move I have idea how to play
against that but like I thought I don't
get
illusions that might have something
special there but at least you have some
idea of what are you playing here
Quincey talk now has become quite
popular is the new age of just basics
which earlier nobody played you know and
it seems a little bit ridiculous no but
ok now has become popular it has some
this boku Indian ideas but ok the
old-fashioned a six a four Bishop d7
root D one here 93 so this I have played
in a in 2012 with the Josh freedo who
was here before me
okay this patient it has a lot the main
theoretical line in my opinion has a lot
of subtleties and it's not easy to play
with black at all I think it basically I
think its position with two results what
I mean by 2 is added whether you win or
if he defends quite well and he plays
very well can make a draw but ok it's
not easy at all so here route c1 and I
think it the whole position is quite the
critical for black maybe black you know
all these guys cracking because he
played one game before that against
coming he had certain problems maybe
they have it analyzed now toti draw but
still it was it's nothing in spare so it
in this game with George I think it was
85 like take take III Queenie 7 maybe
not bad but quite logical now here Ruby
for Queen Ito now you're having some
problems you know with the weak pawn
structure like let's say if you play
here what would you play in what would
white plane he didn't play Queen before
but what would you do you think it white
will play you know exactly this is the
right position apart because you need
these pieces and pressure and pressure
in the endgame because okay he has more
disease and basically the play is mainly
on one flank and on one flank tonight is
more powerful than the bishop now
because it's like a more special piece
when it's on both flanks and it's an
open pigeon then the bishop can shoulder
the long-range
but it's not the case so yeah I will
take him pay route c1 I remember it he
played here something like okay exactly
the same I probably would have paid on
e5 probably something like that like
with which we've talked like take here
and on this I can probably take here
let's say and play route b5 no I still
you have to prove me that you know you
can make a draw maybe you can but you
know this type of question with two
results and when you have energy okay in
this in in early years you have a lot of
energy in your focus and this is like
technical portion I I like to play a lot
here he played Josh Queen d7 rootsy 1e5
but still got into into a lot of trouble
was like take here here take Queen a4
pleasant and okay here you know winning
endgame of that I made a very grave
mistake just lactose an idea to and
enough that it was like a miraculous
rook ending which which anything a draw
it's quite it's quite curious that here
as far as I remember although this was
played quite long at all on this move I
just took on a five Queen e2 taken
Duquesne game was lost although after
that I made some but but here how the
end is changed the the world but I still
prefer you know our human vision because
we can play just like us like humans we
came play day when I looked at this game
quite a few years ago he was saying that
[ __ ] a troll I want Queen h4 which
really in our human logic is okay I
played Queen a phone I'll be back
know starting to exploit another King I
still don't like it although probably of
course being a much better player and
she probably is right but okay I mean I
try for example in chess and I can
advise you try to play things which you
understand what's happening because even
I remember one out interview of an ant
one of the greatest player of the
history he was saying about these
problems with the memory with the
recording a lot of analysis because
these guys they play a lot of things
they have a lot of analysis teams
working for them so they were asking him
they were so very good or they how do
you cope with this and he was saying
some detail but also meshed one thing if
you have some position in which the
analysis are very complex and the engine
is saying okay this is winning but you
look at the road after some time and you
don't know what's happening but I don't
go in this position but it may be favor
but but if you're like a human you have
no idea and we are talking about an ant
one of this you have no idea what's
happening
so probably even during a game you you
won't have an idea what's exactly
happening if it's some you know crazy
stuff like one position I was working
today with the King on d1 straight out
of the opening with white and I'm not
talking about Carson Carson so one of
the ideas in in opening line I almost
playing but in other similar line well
King on d1 and he was telling me the
computer that okay Billy three and I am
I and it maybe whitey better well maybe
but I don't like it so I prefer not to
look at something which I understand so
oh yeah this is like the idea of this
main line of course accepted the main
line there are many more things which
we've played here in this bridge game so
here Bishop c6 93 ended here let me okay
let me first show you
mmm how was the game
come on three minutes players like
normal players play nothing special
chest and okay how it could clear my
opponent I remember plate one week move
I've seen this move and I have it
analyzed like I told many years ago very
profoundly like almost everything but of
course you don't remember saying I
remember I played bits with this mofei
a5 like Evo here 95 night before Queen
Ito now place here I take rotation d3
this is a very unpleasant position and
this is to say the least
very bad look at the move key plate in
this bliss game why I say this game
because this was the last game the last
game which is
in this view so they cut the guy played
a move which I have it now and I'll show
it to you that is so he played here
basics and now you play a typical Britta
temple move 95 so but I really have
point out d5 he is very very strong any
Fife and I and then Knight takes from
defy then you can be you can trust me
this is like almost force in a fourth
way lost for black of course during the
the game I couldn't these are I played
95 here I don't remember if I played
defy for Queenie to first but the game
or something like that here nothing
special the chess here 94 maybe Bishop
d6 but ok he played Bishop c5 and I
played Queen f3 yeah at least you know
you try to control the g4 square no
after I sure that I haven't played like
some kind of a real chess put away for
three minutes game at least you know
don't try to blunt an IG photo only this
you know happens uh since I'm okay so
Queen f3 Knight before Bishop g5 now
this was a natural move although here
for a few seconds I was looking in some
situation earlier when I played Queen e2
yeah something like that when I took
here here but I don't know I was looking
during the game for a couple of seconds
of ideas like no d6 taken if you take Z
to Knight takes when f7 but ok because I
didn't want to get embarrass you know
people to see that probably I miss some
easy tactics away I don't know if it's
working I have to to check it but okay
in this game let's let the I played here
visual g5
so here night before Bishop g5 Bishop e7
now we can maybe play something else but
I thought that this move like this it
comes
these are h4 h 6'i take take we net for
probably an equal position but okay at
least we have some ideas you know with
d6 you want you are better better in the
center he has a tool bishop but okay you
have dominance in the center and this
Indian bit is always better to be active
you notice - to have some thread of
course he'll probably have to play
something like 27 normal position but
here like it happens in this very quick
game
did he make like a huge blunder what the
the first move is really bad and after
that it the idea this move is to make a
blunder day so Bishop takes c3 a bad
move obviously B takes from c3 and our
gate he has to play 96 but the position
is already in my opinion quite bad but
okay this really is Tarragona how do you
win here in a here there is no magic I
mean it's super simple because I just
take no taken ID trainer and he loses
the piece oh the guy even played way
when I play this ie I didn't see
anything because okay there is nothing
to I mean on here you just play or you
can even play rotation d5 winning a
piece and you can click on play here no
but I I saw I think he played c6 I just
played here this is the only line I saw
here and on this I play here he's ruling
the bishop and on g6 I have Queen h3 no
please getting back home and in winning
material but he even preferred here to
play take normal hidden played c6 know
he took here immediately but the best
thing is in here he resigned because to
t4 follows you have made one sacrifice
but okay
the goddess chess said no give us more
give us to give even the bishop so but
okay but here just to give you one one
idea so in this old analysis of the
whole of these positions like quite a
few years ago and this this really
existed but of course I couldn't
remember so okay
we should before is one of the most
a five is really bad one and b6 is
really bad
d5 yeah the best move which I didn't
play e5 and now it's very bad no 98 and
such ideas combinatory visual d5 and
they not take you queen and [ __ ] doesn't
care coordination so only maybe in in
normal game to find d v e5 it's not
difficult in these games you play a lot
of how to put them like impulsive moves
like ah this is like easy now if I
thought okay it's not here today maybe
in the in the second like child show you
because it was very interesting that we
played the same position with different
more water which I was you know when I
saw there was a match in 2017 in chess
that coma kid it was a tournament but
maybe to semi-final Carson played they
play summer for matches calm which I
didn't know before so now as watching at
all the matches that they play format 5
+ 2 then 3 plus 2 then 1 minutes plus
maybe - yeah so very interesting matches
and in one of the game which I watched
life life I mean how they are playing on
on chess calm it was an incredible game
he warned against saw this game exactly
what I've played today and he won't is
such a fashion that it was I am sorry -
how I record exactly how he took the
decision it was like like incredible
genius I mean just to watch how how
everything was clear for him and in one
moment he stopped and he thought exactly
in the morning he had like a clear
normal situation which gave him an
advantage but he felt the dishes Daman
because he had a her advantage of his
work this was the moment maybe talk have
something better and there was something
better not easy at all because we all
look Otto to see if you hear and he
found it in one minute I mean it's
really like watching like a genius in
inaction I
[Music]